what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here John here so we are going to watch
today the mowgli trailer the andy serkis
edition of the jungle book excited to
see what the difference is before we get
into that i want to give a patron the
day shout out to none other than Scuba
Steve Scuba Steve has a pretty cool
YouTube channel where he shows off his
awesome graffiti artwork that's a little
bit not on the legal side but hey you
should check out the channel anyway and
also he has a really good Instagram you
can see all his crazy awesome designs
and scuba Steve we were talking recently
he told me you start dating a girl who
seems really cool just make sure that
she satisfies you in every way a man
deserves to be satisfied I don't know
what that means but hey
love is love in some areas
[Music]
don't one a I just stopped when they
gain their trust whoa Wow only trust
little brother
[Music]
the jungle is no longer safe for you
[Music]
you must stay in the village
Wow yeah seems closer to the source
material definitely I thought I couldn't
did you
[Music]
[Music]
damn
when you return
look Julie I saw no fear
day you would bring peace to the jungle
Wow
[Music]
damn
amazingly dark but that was mr. Bell's
Theorem okay if you something that
jungle has never seen before
[Music]
oh man a lot more menace from kite I am
hoping this movie has the ending of the
actual source material when he like goes
back and burns it all day like this
kills everyone in the village all the
animals I'm glad that this trailer
focused heavily on the conflict between
being man and being one with the animals
in the jungle the jungle book from
Disney is only a couple years old you
know you have to provide a trailer that
shows that this is gonna be something
this ain't no Disney joint it's like
what he has like the familiar animals of
familiar characters the biggest
difference is the the people in the
village and tones the tone here is
exceptionally darker it's still the epic
scale it still has a lot of great mocap
and there's gonna be a lot of
comparisons between what looked better
mocap and the disney version it will
look better mocap here there's some
stuff that was like that looks better
and there's other parts on like I'm not
sure about that snake they're still
finishing up yeah yeah I wonder how
people are gonna respond to this version
or if people will actually tune out for
it this is an October release
there are even advertising it as like a
darker tone they said sometimes the arc
is telling of the story yeah because the
story is dark like the actual source
material so I don't know what tone
they're exactly gone for they're trying
to find a hybrid between the actual
source material and the like the Disney
animated version I feel like they were
going anywhere near Disney really yeah I
think I mean at least from this trailer
and especially with billing it like just
coming straight out and be like this is
the darkest version you have to be at
least pg-13 or R if they're gonna do
that I feel like it'll be at least a
pg-13 for how expensive it is I kind of
doubt they'll go it's a Cobra movie too
so that says something about like you
wouldn't see my faith in this if this
was the family of Jungle Book Phil I
doubt they would put it in October no no
no and I mean hey the the values all
look great I do like that they're kind
of shooting it in a different way to
like even just the visual way they've
captured it seems to be a bit more
different than a real environment it's
seriously it's hard not to do the
comparison because yeah the fact that
the Disney was not that old and there's
just so much that's gonna be kind of
simple
but I really dizzy one was pretty much
just shot all green-screen even the
jungle this looks like some of them
might have actually been shot on
location it looks like a good amount
might have been shot on location
especially with it like you know Andy
circuses experience working on fun like
King Kong for example would probably
give him the insight on how to do that
I'm really curious to see it because of
and eServices direction on the film and
Mowgli - I mean I don't know who this
actor is and I know they made a big deal
when the Disney remake came out about
who's playing Mowgli and all that but I
mean this kid also looks like he's gonna
do a great job and be a bit more intense
because what's so endearing about Mowgli
in Jon Favreau's version is he is kind
of sweet and yeah just a little boy he's
just a little boy and this seems like a
kid who's like really been thrust into a
situation where he's got to grow up fast
and weird really conflicted this kid
yeah I'm like who he should be yeah it
he seems kind of disturbed I mean and
that's the the more realistic take on
this yeah he is gonna be a bit of a
savage I suppose I'm hoping this movie
turns out to be a box office hit I'm
curious on how they're going to approach
the further marketing of this film
because especially if it does go way
darker yeah how how are they gonna
promote this and not get it confused
with audiences that are not aware of all
the behind the scenes we're aware of
this stuff because of the fact that we
follow movies but for people who don't
follow movie news we just watch this
movie I can imagine from just an average
audience perspective that it just looks
like a darker jungle book movie it would
be hard to tell like how different is
this really this it looks like a less
fun version of that fun in a different
way but just a mature version yeah one I
also do admire there are at least three
or four images in this trailer but they
have those images that are just like
paintings yeah tableaus you know what
his visual eye is gonna turn into you
know and what what total there he's got
alright guys well are you excited for
Mowgli do you think it'll be better than
the live-action Jon Favreau version well
we get a dark Lion King movie you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell
also check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A is music
video coverage would love to have you
become a patronage a to die